are you kind of welcome chaos at first
as the the power of my creativity and
then by itself with a little help from
me the chaos becomes order and then of
course I have a plan and I acquire the
ingredients that the plan needs ok you
know like making a dish one good way to
put chaos into order is and it works for
me and one should try it maybe it works
for you too is to make a list a list of
subjects for example if I'm about to
write a book or a chapter of a book on
on something I'm going to put a list of
the thing that I have to talk about and
then the list becomes unbearably long of
course and how can this stupid list
which is an editor how can at least can
distill and help you as a writer in my
example to arrive to starting to write
clearly and sing simply a passage of
your book and well then there is the
process of editing so maybe it's not
editing maybe it's more compressing or
revisiting so I take this ridiculous
list and I start scratching things that
where they came from my mind but are to
be deleted
oh I start associating those three items
actually the only one so I compress I
associate I can seal certain things also
of course more words or more you know
thoughts would come and then at the end
that list becomes very naturally a
blueprint a synopsis a guideline and if
you have a blueprint for an architect
you can start doing a three-dimensional
model to show the constructor how you
want your house built so as a writer if
you have a synopsis you can start
writing because it's a skeleton of your
thoughts it distilled things I think
personally my head is really exploding
in all direction when I am about to
embark into let's say a piece of writing
you can hear in my voice I am getting
excited talking about what people
sometimes have fear what
is a blank surface or a blank calling
and what can you do
so that list and later on the arrival
reflection moment is what I need to
start being intelligible on the page